hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 11 video the
sound and the fury so we got to meet
Pied Piper hartley rathaway so i'm gonna
do an explainer for his character like a
character history from the comics and
then i'll talk about some of the
reverse-flash stuff that we learned lots
of new details so we still have like a
ton of episodes left this season so I
think it's a little too soon to guess
exactly what's going on but we did get
some cool clues and some really awesome
Easter eggs that I'll explain ok so just
careful for spoilers from the episode
just cuz I'll be referencing this week's
episode as well as some moments from
last week's episode hartley rathaway is
the son of the two characters that we
saw last week the ones that had the
painting that the roads were trying to
steal as Harrison wells explained they
ostracized him for being gay which
totally sucks so instead of joining the
family business he joins STAR Labs and
became a physicist because he's a genius
on the level of Harrison wells well
Harrison wells is kind of hiding a lot
of things so maybe he's not quite as
smart as Harrison wells
that was one of the really big things
about them bringing the character on the
show they wanted a character that they
would have to defeat on an intellectual
level they didn't want someone that the
flash could just outrun or outspend
that's one of the problems with
superheroes having friends with
unlimited funds is like if you need a
really cool piece of technology you can
just fabricate it no problems money
isn't an issue so they wanted to bring a
rogue on that would challenge them on a
different level the funny thing is is
the showrunners described the character
as thinking of himself as something of
an evil Harry Potter which gives new
meaning to the chess game it reminded me
of the Harry Potter chess games like the
big real-life chess game at the end of
that first movie he kind of does look
like he's cosplaying Harry Potter a
little bit with those robes on so in the
comics his actually his first appearance
was the same first appearance as Gorilla
Grodd so he and Gorilla Grodd debuted at
the same time it was the flash number
106 Menace of the super gorilla slashed
the Pied Piper of peril and the
interesting thing about that story is
pipe Piper helped the flash helped barry
allen defeat Gorilla Grodd so he has
worked with the flash in the past he's
not like a completely evil character
like some of the flash villains he is
one of the first DC characters to come
out as gays he's actually captain
Singh's boyfriend in the in the flash
comics they haven't fully explained it
although captain Singh has mentioned his
boyfriend it's just interesting to note
that one of the Rogues is dating the
captain of the police department
just a funny thought like oh here's my
boyfriend super criminal as the show
explained he has a really strained
relationship with his parents in the
comics they actually they were murdered
and he was framed for it
he was even hypnotized to believe that
he had done it eventually he got cleared
and they found out that it was the evan
mccullough mirror master that had done
it on blacksmiths orders so he and
mirror master had this really big feud
so if mirror master ever comes on the
show i'll be interested to see if they
play it that way okay so here we go
getting into top five moments now so
number five Harrison wells
running around without the reverse-flash
suit on so I have to explain I saw a
couple of people commenting on Twitter
that were a little confused by the red
lightning a lot of people were thinking
that he might be a future version of
Barry Allen because of the the red
streak just explain what's going on the
Speed Force whenever the flash is
running he gives off yellow lightning
the reverse flash is the one that gives
off red lightning so regardless of who
Harrison wells really is which which
version of the reverse flash he is he's
not the same person as Barry Allen but
it's just a lot of fun as we get deeper
into the season and we start learning
more and more about him as we start
seeing him act more as the reverse flash
number four the prodigal son returns
meet hartley rathaway I really like the
crazy relationship that we saw in the
flashbacks between Harrison wells and
Hartley like both of them are very
abrasive people like they're both kind
of but they have this
camaraderie this Brotherhood of minds of
all the things in the episode that I
feel like they could have done a little
bit better it would have been explaining
what Hartley's purpose was at STAR Labs
Harrison wells had that explainer room
he's like oh you know his parents hated
him because he's gay he was my number
one guy it doesn't really do justice to
the pathos that his character has in the
past obviously we know why he's so
pissed off in present day because of
what Harrison wells did to him but the
really interesting thing is that he is
the second flash villain or the next in
the line of rogues that has goaded the
flash into a fight on false pretense so
remember in the last episode the Rogues
already had the painting they started
the fight with the flash with the sole
purpose of taking him down Pied Piper
did the exact same thing so he committed
a crime got the flash to take him in so
that he could get the stuff that he
needed to kill the flash in a later
encounter
he's just the next in a long line of
people to pull a fast one on the flash
he can make as many jokes about that as
you want it does a really good job of
playing into this theme
of your heroes letting you down you
letting your heroes down broken trust
there's gonna be a lot of that going
around later this season moving on to
number three Joe and Eddie are
investigating Harrison wells behind
Barry's back
they just gotten done with that moment
where Barry was telling Joe that he's
still his number one guy no one's gonna
come between us like the same
conversation that Harrison wells had
with hartley rathaway which is kind of
funny it's all about trust in
hero-worship and then right away Eddie
walks in and says you really want to do
this you really want to investigate
Harrison and Joe's like hell yeah I do
clearly Barry is going to be very
disappointed in Joe at some point just
like he's gonna be disappointed in
Harrison when he finds out what's really
going on like his real reverse-flash
plan when you think about it it seems
like everyone's gonna wind up hating
each other at the end of the season
everybody has something about themselves
that they're not telling someone else
moving on to number two Cisco versus
Pied Piper it's so fun to see Cisco
finally get a rivalry like he has a
nemesis now he seems like such a
positive person it's hard to believe
that there's someone that he does not
like they tease the upcoming firestorm
episode at the end when hartley rathaway
is like I know all about firestorm
you're gonna let me out because I'm
gonna help you find him that's another
situation like you have with the flash
and the reverse flash like our Harrison
and Barry Allen as well as the roses
captain cold and heat wave there's
always like a pair of characters one of
them creates an elaborate plan they need
the other person to help them and they
might not like him quite as much they
might have to put up with them so like
Captain Cold not a huge fan of heat wave
but really needs his help in taking down
the flash then you have the reverse
flash or Harrison wells who wants to
siphon the Speed Force for some
elaborate plan can't really tell if he
likes the flash he's at least he's
tolerating the flash because he needs
him and now you have Cisco and hartley
rathaway so this was gonna be forced to
work with someone he doesn't like
because he wants to find his friend I
really like the way they're structuring
the narrative that way where you have
these elaborate plans that each of the
characters are involved in and they
always need someone else to complete it
and in the story of their relationship
with that other person becomes really
interesting and my number one moment
Harrison wells explains his plan so if
it wasn't totally clear obviously he's
it using the Tachyon device to siphon
Speed Force it seems like he's going to
take Barry Allen's milkshake and drink
it up like that that's what his ultimate
plan is the temporary fix being the
Tachyon device
the real question is is what does he
want to do with the speedforce once he
gets it I think he's going to try and
alter the timeline his relationship with
the speedforce also raises a lot of
questions what I think is going on is
they're mixing and matching details from
different versions of the reverse-flash
so Harrison wells character draws from
aspects of a bar thon as well as hunter
zolomon so he's not one or the other the
show is just kind of like mixing and
matching aspects so it's faithful to the
comics but not in the literal sense like
it's not copy and paste if you're not
familiar with the story of ale Barth on
so he's from the 25th century in that
era the speedforce does not exist there
are no flashes they do have a flash
Museum where they study the Speed Force
Hale bard becomes an expert in flash
studies you know really idolizes Barry
Allen there was a lot of talking about
people idolizing people in this episode
so the students at the school there at
the flash Museum named him professor
zoom because he's so smart because he
knows so much about the flash eventually
he comes into possession of the Flash's
suit uses that to replicate the
experiment that created the Barry Allen
flash and then becomes the reverse flash
but he can't become the reverse flash if
Barry Allen never became the flash right
now he seems more like a battery
operating at half charge like he keeps
having to recharge himself every once in
a while that also seems like a narrative
device because if his powers worked the
same way Barry Allen's did then why
wouldn't he just SuperSpeed all over the
place all the time if you've never read
it the story that immediately precedes
flashpoint deals with the idea of the
multiverse and how Barry Allen is the
generator of the Speed Force so like all
the other flashes all over the
multiverse all originate from Barry
Allen he's the person that creates the
Speed Force so to speak that all of them
all live off so if he dies the Speed
Force dies with him which is why it's so
important that he stays alive Tom
Cavanagh also the TCAs described himself
as a time-traveling thief so I think if
you're gonna call him one flash of the
other I'm gonna call him a Oh Bart
Thawne
but I don't think that's exactly the way
his characters gonna play out feel free
to leave all your theories in the
comments though we all we all have great
reverse-flash theories we're gonna get a
whole lot more Harrison wells running
around doing crazy stuff so here's my
big question for you guys do you think
that Harrison wells is a combination of
multiple reverse slashes his character
is from the comics and what do you think
he's gonna do
once he gets Barry Allen's powers once
he takes his speedforce so what'd you
guys think about that here are just some
of the Easter eggs I saw in the episode
so he had Royal Flush gang at the
beginning they were also featured on
arrow too so they're kind of like being
passed around the DC TV universe
believing in heroes heroes believing in
us was a common theme across the entire
episode so if you never read it AO
barred Thawne idolized the Barry Allen
flash before he became the reverse-flash
so you have Barry worshiping the person
who worshipped him as a child it is
really funny Harrison Wells talked about
the road from the earth to the stars I'd
like to believe that's a subtle Easter
Egg for the New Gods Geoff Johns is
getting ready to write like an Orion
comic like a New Gods comic real soon
maybe season two we might see some more
Easter eggs for New Gods but they're a
little more fantastical so I'm not
expecting them on the on the show any
time soon then Pied Piper starts talking
about vibrational frequency everything
has a vibrational frequency so the flash
is able to actually vibrate his
molecules through solid objects so we'll
see him phase through walls hopefully
before the end of this season also the
universe has a vibrational frequency so
he can vibrate into other dimensions
under the right circumstances that would
be like the back door to flash of two
worlds so you know hopefully we'll get
to that in like you know maybe the next
two or three seasons no idea when
they'll get into multiverse if you saw
any other Easter eggs that I didn't
mention somewhere in the video just
write them below in the comments but I'd
say the only big thumbs down I had were
one you know Hartley's character didn't
feel like you know it was quite shown
why he was such a dick in the past
Harrison wells explained it the TV is
very much like a show me not tell me
medium so I feel like the explanation
didn't really do him justice and I
mentioned it before but this is like the
second big rogue to goad the flash into
a fight so at some point they're gonna
have to acknowledge it like okay Barry
fight smarter not fight faster this is
all the process though I mean I mean
this is the story of the flash becoming
the flash getting better so you know you
expect him to fall on his face every
once in a while so next week really
awesome stuff we're gonna get to see
some really cool flash karaoke be sure
to subscribe to get that video we'll get
to see Barry Allen have a real-deal sex
life for those asking my agents of
shield video is gonna post tomorrow
morning and if you haven't seen it
already I just did a trailer breakdown
for Fantastic Four so a whole lot of
superhero stuff happening tonight
there's been a really interesting day so
if you guys haven't seen it yet I did
explainer video for gorilla grodd and
his character history in the comics they
basically they tease that he's gonna be
coming back in season one you can click
here to learn all about that it's gonna
be really cool and you can click here if
you haven't seen that Fantastic Four
trailer thank you so much for watching
let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you